okay so today we're gonna be talking
about the number
three quarters
or not point seven five
unusual i know because it's not a whole
number like not one two three four but
this one is very important in biology
so
max clermont in the 1930s plus the graph
of mass of animal
against
metabolic rate down here we have you
know you'll have
the mouse
he'll have his little legs there
little ears
that's that
that's a mouse
i've ever seen wait do you see my
elephant so somewhere up here a thousand
times heavier you know you'll have
you'll have an elephant let's have a
look let's try this one well that's not
bad dude that's not bad though
well you know it's kind of like a big
mass to be honest and then all the way
all the way up here
you have your blue whale
okay so he plotted the mass against the
metabolic rate of all the animals so
mouse elephant blue whale there was also
mayflies in there and as you might
expect with the bigger animals
they need more energy to survive and
that's what metabolic rate essentially
measures how much energy do you need to
survive so smaller animals need a small
amount of energy bigger animals need
more energy so one one way it could
happen is that since the elephant is a
thousand times heavier as the mouse it
would need a thousand times much more
energy and that if we had that sort of
scaling it would be linear and so we'd
have just a straight line between the
metabolic rate and the mass so the whale
that's a million times heavier than the
mouse so it would need a million times
more energy
or it could be super linear so the
elephant is a thousand times heavier
than the mouse so it needs say a million
times more it actually needs more than
the line originally the linear line what
max kleiber found was that it's neither
of those
the curve actually tapers off and so
it's below the straight line
what that means is that the bigger you
get although you need more energy you
can spend it more efficiently so down
here with your mayflies and your your
spiders and all your insects
they need very little energy but
they they don't use it very efficiently
and this scale crosses all sizes of
animal right down to cells all the way
up to the blue whale it's amazing how
this curve
describes all the animals and how does
this curve linking the three quarters
what max found was that this curve
is that the metabolic rate
is proportional to the mass
to power three
quarters
now statistically it was a it was around
three quarters so something like 0.74 or
0.76 but on average that's what
biologists now take so this is kleiber's
rule or the three-quarters rule well
when they found three-quarters one thing
we want to understand is where does that
number come from is it just a
coincidence that it's three-quarters or
is there some reasoning behind that we
can get at so originally when they were
looking for this three quarters they
were trying to link metabolic rate and
the mass and so your metabolic rate is
how much you use energy and you use
energy they thought mostly through
heating yourself and so what affects the
heat is well your surface area the
bigger your surface area the more you
lose more you lose heat and the bigger
you are in terms of your mass
again the more heat you will have so
they looked at spherical animals
so just for the sake of mathematics
we're going to treat these animals as
spheres because your main body is sort
of spherical and you can at least get an
approximation of what you'd expect to
get out at the end we draw a sphere
and we give it a radius
r
so that's the body of the animal okay so
even if you're a mayfly you'd be a tiny
sphere if you're a blue whale you'd be
an enormous sphere
so the area
the surface area of this sphere
that's proportional
to r squared
as you increase r if you double r
your surface area increases by four
the volume
of the sphere
is proportional to r cubed so if you
double the radius your volume increases
by eight so using this idea that the the
metabolic rate is proportional to these
two guys you'd expect it to be
metabolic rate it's proportional
to our
two thirds so you'd get a two-thirds
power out so although two-thirds is
quite close to three-quarters we wanted
to understand where that difference is
coming from because
they're close so it's a good first
approximation but there has to be some
reason that we're not getting three
quarters so what mathematicians have
looked at is using the fractal structure
inside us to deliver that energy so the
circulation system that we have the
veins the arteries and the capillaries
is self-similar all the way down as you
zoom into the veins they look like the
whole system and that's what a fractal
is
and using that fractal structure you can
link the mouse to the elephant to the
blue whale
and that does spit out
the three-quarters power law at the end
of it so as i said yeah the the bigger
the animal the more efficient you're
using your energy
but using this idea of the circulation
system being a fractal you can then
start using it to look at cities because
what are cities well they got their own
circulation system because they have
roads that deliver cars to places they
have
water pipes they have electricity cables
and you can plot those certain things
against population and you get very
similar graphs that follow this power
rule it may not be three quarters but
you'll get that is proportional to the
population and it's less than linear and
they're usually following a quarter
structure
so whatever this number may be on top
you'll usually find a four on the bottom